[Music]
what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime opera and in this video we'll be
talking about sword art
online oh yeah now we all know that
there are a lot of people especially in
the anime youtube community who really
hate sao but it is also true that there
are a lot of fans of sao who really love
it
i've said this before but i personally
think that sao is not
nearly as bad as some people pretend it
is i mean sure
hating on sao gets lots of views on
youtube but i've seen
dozens of anime that were way worse than
sao
when season 1 first came out an sao blew
up in popularity you can definitely say
that the show was overrated
but at this point i would say that sao
is actually
over hated and even though there are
many people who seem to hate
sao it is becoming more and more likely
that sao
and shows like it will be the future of
anime in a few important ways
whether you love or hate sao and i guess
you could say that i both love
and hate it because there are some
aspects of sao that i love and some that
i do kind of hate
the popularity of sword art online has
had a significant
impact on the anime industry and more
and more anime series seem to be
deliberately following in the same
footsteps as sao
because let's face it they all want a
taste of that sweet sweet popularity
i will explain what i mean and why i
personally both love
and hate sao at the same time but before
i get
into it if you enjoyed this type of
content you can leave a like to let me
know
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell this video will
specifically address the sao
anime up to and including mother's
rosario
and the ordinal scale movie but i will
not spoil the alicization arc
the gun gale online spin-off or the rest
of the light novel for you so if you're
not caught up to those
no worries now the one thing that i
absolutely love about sao and the
primary reason why i stuck with this
series for so long is that when you
actually think about it
each arc of this series has a great
premise
i'm a big fan of science fiction and
i've read a lot of classic
and modern sci-fi and i've also watched
a ton of science fiction movies
tv shows and anime and believe it or not
the initial premise of each sao arc has
echoes of some of the most influential
and critically acclaimed works of
science fiction
let's start with the very first arc in
the story the aincrad arc
the premise of this first arc is that a
bunch of everyday people become
trapped inside a new virtual reality
game they are unable to lock out and
leave the virtual world and if they die
in the game they die in real life when i
first began watching sao
i thought that this was an extremely
interesting premise and i absolutely
loved the first
episode of the anime i thought it did a
great job of setting up the world and
the ending of the first episode
compelled me to keep watching to see
what happens next
this idea of being trapped in a virtual
reality based game is certainly nothing
new
and classic sci-fi franchises like tron
already explored the same territory
decades ago
not to mention that other anime
franchises like dot hack
did it too but i actually thought that
sao did a good job of modernizing this
trapped in a virtual reality setting
in the post-world of warcraft era a lot
has been said about kirito the
protagonist of seo being
too overpowered but i was willing to
look past it in the first
arc because the series cleverly
established that kirito was one of the
1000 beta testers for the original sao
game
so it made sense that since he had more
experience playing it kirito would have
an advantage over most other players in
sao i'll save my issues with sao
including the aincrad arc for a little
bit later but now let's talk about the
second
arc in the series the alpheim arc the
premise of this arc is that
after most of the surviving players of
the original swordart online game were
able to log out successfully and wake up
some survivors of sao including asuna
failed to wake up for some
unknown reason we later learned that
asuna's consciousness is being held
captive inside alfheim online the game
that is the successor to
sao and this is all part of a plan by
sugo nobuyuki who was able to hack
into the sao server and reroute the
minds of the missing
sao players so that he can use them as
test subjects in his research on how to
manipulate
memories nobuyuki also intended to
inherit
asuna's family fortune by persuading her
father to let him marry asuna while she
is still
unconscious now i have no idea how this
would even work
but maybe japan has marriage laws that
are more inclusive of the consciousness
challenged anyway this idea of hacking
people's brains and manipulating their
minds is another
extremely cool sci-fi concept with a lot
of potential
especially as modern technology
continues to move towards virtual
reality and cybernetic implants and
enhancements
just think of ghost in the shell and how
heavily the idea of hacking a cybernetic
brain
plays into the story as a whole now am i
saying that sao does as good of a job in
handling these intriguing sci-fi
concepts as
ghost in the shell does no definitely
not and i will explain
why but now let's look at the third arc
the phantom
bullet arc the premise is as follows
within a shooter game called
gun gale online those players who are
killed by a specific individual known as
death gun somehow end up dying in real
life
those who are shot in the game by death
gun instantly disconnect from the game
and turn up dead in real life a few days
later here again we have a situation
where the setup to the ark
is incredibly interesting we have a
truly fascinating mystery in which the
line between the fantasy world of the
game and the real world is blurred
and we are desperately trying to figure
out how it is possible for someone to
kill a player in a game
and also have that person instantly die
in real life
this is not the same situation as with
the aincrad arc where all the players
were trapped and everyone who died in
the game died in real life
instead only this one mysterious villain
called
death gun has the ability to kill
someone in the game and have them
also die in real life and i remember
that i was personally extremely
interested in figuring out how this was
even possible
i also felt that this premise explored
some very intriguing questions about the
modern world and just how connected our
online lives
are to our physical lives i mean we all
spend so much time on the internet
interacting with all sorts of strangers
so much so that we sometimes forget that
meeting the wrong person online
can be pretty dangerous and death gun is
the living embodiment
of that very thing again this is another
premise that i loved a premise that kept
me hooked and that made me think about
the philosophical implications of our
increasingly high-tech society which is
the effect that all good science fiction
tends to have on me
then we have mother's rosario which is
technically a side story rather than an
independent arc
the premise here is that people who are
physically disabled or terminally ill in
the physical world can now
thanks to modern technology live a
fulfilling life in the virtual world
where they are not hindered by the
physical limitations of their bodies
yet again here we have a brilliant
sci-fi
concept and this same concept has been
explored in a number of highly praised
works of science fiction
including of course the critically
acclaimed sci-fi series
black mirror one of its episodes
entitled san junipero has basically the
same
exact premise and with technology
advancing as rapidly as it is
it isn't too far-fetched to think that
in a few years people with physical
limitations could abandon the physical
world and embrace
virtual reality instead but then the
question is
where do we draw the line how long
before individuals who might be
perfectly healthy physically decide
that they prefer the virtual world to
their real lives
some would say that a troubling
percentage of people is already heading
in this direction so how long before our
society has to address the serious
consequences that will emerge as a
result
of this shift from the physical to the
virtual these are all
important and profoundly interesting
questions that
if handled well can make for some
amazing science fiction
and finally let's look at the premise
for the sao movie
called ordinal scale in ordinal scale
the setting moves from a virtual world
into augmented reality and the line
between the real world and the virtual
world becomes even more blurry as real
physical spaces are transformed into
fantastical settings through the power
of augmented reality or
ar ar technology has been growing
rapidly in the past
five to ten years and the phenomenon of
pokemon go
back in 2016 demonstrated that the
premise of ordinal scale is both
plausible
and highly interesting now of course the
initial
avalanche of interest that pokemon go
generated when it first came out didn't
last
and realistically that level of hype and
popularity for
any game is unsustainable back when it
first came out the streets were
literally full of people playing pokemon
go
children were playing together with
their parents and grandparents it was
truly a phenomenon
but even though the popularity of
pokemon go is nowhere near those initial
levels
there are still a lot of people playing
pokemon go even now so this game was by
no means a flop
and it isn't hard to imagine that as
augmented reality technology advances
something like the ar mmorpg that we see
in the ordinal scale movie
could appear in our own world in the
near future
so there we are again we have a
fascinating and plausible sci-fi concept
that has the potential to create some
amazing stories
so then why is it that despite the fact
that each story arc has an intriguing
and promising premise
sword art online continues to receive so
much hate even though i feel that the
show's faults have been greatly
exaggerated over the years
i think i know why sao has failed to
live up to its full potential
thus far while i love the science
fiction elements in sao and the initial
premise of each arc
i also kind of hate the fact that the
character development in sao
fails to live up to the promising
premise in order to create a great story
you need a great
premise but in order to make the story
truly amazing you also need great
characters who go through meaningful
development throughout the course of the
series
granted sao spends a lot of time on the
character of kirito and on his
relationship with asuna which i like
and i was happy to see their
relationship actually progress in a real
way
something that doesn't often happen in
harem anime however the real
issue with sao is the lack of character
development for
everyone else other than kirito and
asuna and this includes the villains
you can't fully explore a cool sci-fi
premise if you don't
develop your characters because the
social economic and philosophical impact
of modern technology can only be fully
explored through its effects on the
characters within the story
think for a moment about the side
characters in sao
including lisbeth the blacksmith lifa
the cousin
cinone silica klein and so on
all of these characters play an
important role at some point in the
story but then
after their main story arc finishes they
simply fade into the background and
they're just
kind of there they're just hanging
around and not doing anything too
important while we focus on kirito
asuna and whichever new characters are
relevant in the current arc
compare this to another shonen series
the seven deadly sins or nanatsuno
taizai
sure that series could have just focused
on the relationship between the captain
of the sins meliodus
and his love interest elizabeth in the
same way that sao focuses on kirito and
asuna but instead the seventh deadly sin
spends
a lot of time developing the other
characters including
the six remaining members of the sins
each character has their own unique
backstory and the relationships between
the characters continue to grow and
develop as the series goes on
furthermore these characters do not
simply fade into the background
once a new arc begins instead each
member of the seven deadly sins has
their own
important role to play in the story even
now as the manga
approaches chapter 300 yui the ai
is also a great example of sao's failure
to develop its characters
the idea of an advanced computer program
becoming self-aware and developing
artificial intelligence is another major
theme in science fiction
and it has been explored in everything
from william gibson's neuromancer and
the tron
franchise to ghost in the shell and the
terminator to name just a few
when yui was first introduced i loved
this idea of having an
ai become self-aware and begin to
interact with actual people within the
sao
game but after she is initially
introduced yui
also becomes a relatively static side
character who considers kirito and asuna
to be her parents even though they're
not
since yui possesses superior artificial
intelligence
a lot more focus could have been placed
on her development
how her understanding of human beings
and their relationships changes and
matures
and a lot more time could have been
spent on what the existence of such an
advanced ai means for the society in
which sao is taking place
the fact that such an advanced ai exists
an ai that is able to interact
directly with human beings is a
revolutionary technological development
and yet yui is relegated to a side
character whose primary role seems to be
to act
cute and help kirito and asuna once in a
while with technical support
and don't even get me started on the
villains
kaiaba the creator of the original sao
and nerve gear seems to be interesting
at first
but as we learn more about him we
realize that his character is shallow
and his motivations for doing what he
did
make no sense i mean sure we can
understand why kaibab would want to have
full control of the virtual world he
created
power is definitely a strong motivator
for human beings
but why did kayaba decide that thousands
of innocent people needed to die
in sao he could have still controlled
the virtual world without having anyone
actually die and even if he wanted to
keep people trapped in the game he could
have held their consciousnesses captive
just like nobuyuki aka fairy king oberon
does to asuna and the others
literally no one had to die let alone
innocent teenagers who just wanted to
play a game
kaiba eventually scans his brain and
permanently transfers his consciousness
into the virtual world which is another
thought-provoking sci-fi
concept but the full potential of this
premise
is never explored and not much is done
with kaioba's character
even though there were so many
possibilities to do more
our boy fairy king oberon is also a very
one-dimensional villain he is an evil
psycho who wants money and power
but other than being extremely punchable
for the evil douchebag that he
is there is nothing relatable or complex
about his character
what drove him to become the way that he
is what is his belief system and the
true driving force behind his actions
human beings are complicated it is very
rare for someone to just be purely
evil or purely good but there is nothing
complicated about
oberon he's just an abusive psycho who
wants money and power
other villains like death gun also turn
out to be one-dimensional and their
motivations turn out to be pretty
dubious once we learn
more about them and in the ordinal scale
movie the primary villain is a professor
whose daughter died in the original sao
and he wants to revive her by stealing
all of the memories of her from the sao
survivors
he needs to steal the memories in order
to reconstruct her personality in the
virtual world
turning her into a sort of ai but if you
ask me this entire concept makes
literally no sense since the memories
that others have of the daughter could
not possibly help reconstruct her true
personality
the way that we see and perceive other
people that we meet is completely
different from the way that they see and
perceive themselves and unless you can
read minds you can't possibly know what
someone else is thinking or
feeling on the inside so stealing the
inherently subjective memories that sao
survivors have of his daughter could do
little in terms of reconstructing the
daughter's true personality
which means that the professor's entire
elaborate master plan
makes very little sense to me and this
is the main issue that i have with sao
we start off with an intriguing sci-fi
premise and main characters like kirito
and asuna that we can definitely work
with
but not nearly enough effort is spent on
developing the other characters or on
constructing a logical and compelling
plot line
each arc consists of either kirito or
asuna or both
obtaining new skills and weapons and
using them to destroy one-dimensional
unforgettable villains with some minor
help from the side characters
we always end up with a very simplistic
dynamic of good guy kirito versus a
one-dimensional villain
and of course we know that the story
will end with kirito training
obtaining new skills or weapons and then
defeating the villain
and this is unfortunate because as i
mentioned so many times in this video
sao has the potential to explore more
complex and nuanced sci-fi themes
themes that other anime like ghost in
the shell and psychopaths have explored
so successfully
and the truth is that the sao formula
may well be the future
of anime if we take a look at the surge
in isekai anime in recent years it is
clear that the goal of most of these
anime is to attract viewers with an
intriguing premise an ordinary person
just like you
ends up in a really cool fantasy world
full of women who want you
and plot twist you are also extremely
powerful despite being completely new to
this world and then once they suck
viewers in with the escapist power
fantasy premise
they spend very little effort on
character development and plot
the protagonist is always good pure
overpowered and a chick magnet and of
course his enemies are all evil
one-dimensional psychopaths who are
defeated
as soon as he finds a new more powerful
sword or spell
or nunchucks or whatever this formula
could be the future of anime because
it's easier to produce
shows of this type it's easier to create
a cool premise and then just make
formulaic arcs in which the protagonist
is kicking ass in roughly the same way
every time
only the villains and the items being
used to defeat the villains are changing
it is much harder to create a gripping
and coherent overarching plotline that
includes meaningful character
development for all the relevant cast
members
and that treats its villains as actual
multi-dimensional human beings with
complex
thoughts feelings and motivations as far
as sword art
online goes i think it gets more hate
than it deserves and i will definitely
still watch the alicization arc as it
comes out in anime form
but sao has the potential to be so
much better and we need to expect more
from franchises like
sao otherwise the future of anime will
be series with intriguing concepts that
never put in the work
necessary to achieve their full
potential and we are going to keep
seeing a bunch of bad
sao clones like isekaiwa smartphone
popping up
every new anime season at least that's
my opinion
but let me know what you guys think do
you agree with my take on
sao and the future of anime or do you
think that i'm wrong an isekaiwa
smartphone is actually a modern classic
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more videos
like it leave a like to let me know
if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell
also be sure to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest updates
and a big thank you to ac design for
editing this and other videos for us
he's doing a great job be sure to check
him out link in the description
as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]